katia bonjour les niçois une nouvelle
fois la cible d'une attaque terroriste
oui en effet les riverains et les niçois
hier n'ont pas manqué de nous le
rappeler ils sont encore sous le choc
des précédents attentats le plus
dramatique restant évidemment celui de
la promenade des anglais le 14 juillet
2016 qui avait fait 86 morts
évidemment la colère la tristesse était
grande hier les niçois disais pourquoi
encore et pourquoi nous une fois de plus
alors que les communautés ici distille
s'entendent très bien et d'ailleurs
devant la basilique devant laquelle je
me trouve les communautés sont venus
hier il y avait des personnes de
confession juive et que personne de
confession musulmane chrétienne il y
avait des personnes athées qui sont
venus communier hier maître des bougies
des bouquets qui sont d'ailleurs
toujours présents aujourd'hui je vous
propose d'écouter certains d'entre eux
quelqu'un qui porte atteinte à la vie
d'une autre personne
elle n'est pas musulmane donc un
musulman n'est pas terroriste
il autorise ce n'est pas musulman
simplement c'est un barbare tout
simplement un barbare un criminel n'a
pas de religion n'a aucun sentiment est
français il demande sa main quand il
demande simplement de dire nous on veut
une justice
on veut que ces gens là qui sont
recensés par nos services
repartent et qu'on les accompagne
gentiment dans leur planning
et voilà j'ai peur en revanche pour mon
fils pour nos enfants
je ne sais pas dans quel monde ils
vivront et il faut qu'on réagisse parce
que c'est à nous la maintenons notre
niche dans notre génération de leur
préparer de le monde
parce que oui pour eux j'ai peur mais
pour moi j'ai pas peur donc pour le
moment évidemment comme il ya le couvre
fait qu'il est très tôt il n'y a pas
encore de personnes qui viennent
commémorer ce matin mais nous vous
tiendrons au courant au fil de la
journée
merci beaucoup katia technique en direct
de nice et